[Music]
a dramatic surge in lumber prices is
making the dream of home ownership
harder to achieve for many americans the
cost of lumber
is up 250 percent a big increase
in home renovations during the pandemic
drove up demand
and saw mills are having trouble keeping
up maria villarreal is inside a home
under construction near birmingham
alabama maria what are you finding
well you know good morning anthony right
now the contractor that is working on
this exact house says this framing right
here the cost has gone up more than 300
percent
the floors that i'm standing on up 400
percent the plywood right here
up more than 900 percent the cost is
getting so out of control they are
asking the government to step in but the
sawmills that are benefiting from these
higher prices say
that's a bit of an overreach
hard to tell from this view but bob
dixon's southeast alabama mill
is considered small by industry
standards the whole game is to get this
in somebody else's shed not mine
he says logistical issues like staffing
and delivery
are making it hard to respond to the
increase in lumber demand
the issue now with employees being paid
to stay at home
it's not just our industry it's
everywhere you go in addition to the
logistical hurdles
mills are also facing soaring demands
for home renovations
the result lumber prices have tripled in
the last
12 months since april adding roughly 36
thousand dollars to the price of a new
home
it's tough birmingham builder alicia
huey says
higher prices threaten her business and
price homeowners
out of the market so if this is going up
for you
i would imagine then that cost gets
pushed on to the homeowner
it does right now i can't tell anybody
how much a house is going to cost
what does that do the american dream
kills it the ripple effect
now reaching families that need help the
most the non-profit habitat for humanity
no longer taking applications in
birmingham
and huey believes some of the big mills
are taking advantage of the situation
i think it's great from the lumber mills
home builders have told us
that they believe the big mills are the
problem that they're jacking up the
prices is that what's happening
i don't believe any mill can control our
industry our industry
pricing is based on an industry standard
pricing guide it prints every thursday
industry expert paul yonke says at the
start of the pandemic mill operators and
home builders
scaled back to prepare for a recession
that never came
we saw people um you know wanting to
move out of the cities and purchase
new homes we saw people wanting to add
on and make improvements to their home
so that strong surge in demand
at the same time we saw production and
buying decline
is really what drove these prices so
high dixon believes the industry
will correct itself in time they just
hang on
and we will over produce the market we
will respond and the prices they will
come down
that industry expert that we spoke with
actually said that prices are already
starting to decrease and we should see a
significant decrease in the fall when
demand
usually comes down but he also warned do
not
expect pre-pandemic pricing tony
all right the pandemic has really
changed everything maria thank you very
much